bonsoir si des titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 11 octobre les violences
continuent entre israéliens et
palestiniens les efforts internationaux
se multiplient pour un éventuel sommet
entre eux ou de baraki yasser arafat
mais les effets de la crise au
proche-orient de graves conséquences en
france une synagogue à trappes dans les
yvelines est détruite
une enfant de 8 ans française d'origine
comorienne retenu pendant quatre jours
par la police de l'air et des frontières
à roissy nouvel exemple de graves
dysfonctionnements dans l'accueil des
mineurs aux frontières le gouvernement
décide d'interdire l'utilisation dans
l'alimentation de la totalité des
intestins de bovins les boyaux sont
considérés comme à risque
le bâtiment va bien mais il manque de
bras et des lycées professionnels
recherchent des élèves désireux d'avoir
une garantie d'emploi nouveau podium
pour jeannie longo l'exemplaire
championne cities française se classe
deuxième au championnat du monde du
contre la montre à tous et nous serons
en direct à la fin de cette édition avec
jeannie longo depuis plouay comme un
tropisme malsain l'effet des violences
au proche orient depuis dix jours se
traduit en france par d'autres violences
d'autres attentes
les organisations juives et musulmanes
de france appellent bien à éviter tout
dérapage en évoquant la nécessité de la
sagesse et du dialogue mais hier soir
c'est une synagogue à trappes dans les
yvelines qui a été détruite
l'origine criminelle ne fait aucun doute
cet acte condamné par jacques chirac et
le premier ministre survient après
d'autres commis contre des lieux juifs
depuis quelques jours reportage jean
marie n'est et guillaume fautrat
c'était la synagogue de trappes les
pompiers n'ont pas pu sauver ce pavillon
de deux étages hier soir avec 1h30 bidon
incendiaires déposé dans l'entrée à
propager les flammes aidés par un vent
violent
seuls ces rouleaux les objets du cuse
dont été préservé la veille la majorité
de la petite communauté de trappes
étaient réunis dans la synagogue
on était acquis bourdais plus de 100
personnes
fabien enfants ça soit arrivé à ce
moment là vous rendez compte à la
catastrophe
alors donc les gens maintenant alors que
les fidèles tout moment au port de ce
qui se passait ils viendront blues vis
présente devant le bâtiment dimanche et
lundi la police ne fait que tuer plus
que des rondes des voisins auraient vu
des jeunes gens s'enfuir avant le
sinistre mais personne n'a revendiqué
cet attentat qui dans le quartier laisse
perplexe nous respectons toutes sortes
de religions comme les autres personnes
d'autres religions c'est nous respecte
hors jeu d incident de cette gravité
c'est ce que redoutaient les
responsables de la communauté juive
dès dimanche il s'en était ouvert auprès
de jacques chirac et ce soir c'est le
recteur de la mosquée de paris qui se
joint à eux pour un appel au calme
possible vu notre rôle de responsable
religieux de manière à ce que je répète
nos fidèles nos jeunes nos composants de
notre communauté soient responsabilisées
à son tour à la police a renforcé la
protection des lieux de culte mais
depuis le début des affrontements en
israël une vingtaine d'actions contre la
communauté juive ont été commises à
paris et en région parisienne entre
israéliens et palestiniens des échanges
de tirs ont continué aujourd'hui même
s'il yasser arafat a ordonné au fatah
d'éviter les confrontations deux jeunes
palestiniens de 18 ans ont été tués de
part et d'autre et obsèques des victimes
donnent toute la mesure de la tension
s'était ainsi aujourd'hui à naplouse où
claude samper mossière moon suivait des
militaires israéliens
nous sommes au nord de la cisjordanie
la petite colonie juive dit sharp
s'apprête à enterrer l'un des siens le
rabbin lieberman assassiné samedi
dernier
la route qui mène au cimetière est
interdite à la circulation sauf pour les
soldats pour assurer la sécurité de la
cérémonie ils sont plusieurs milliers
disposés dans toute la région
à côté d'eux le service de sécurité de
la colonie
la plupart des colons qui arrive vient
également armés il est responsable
militaire verrouillent leur dispositif
la situation est beaucoup moins tendue
beaucoup beaucoup moins tendue il faut
reconnaître mais on ne veut pas être
on veut pas on veut pas avoir de
surprises depuis hier l'armée constate
un certain déclin de la violence mais
pour cette cérémonie
ils savent que des incidents sont
possibles une heure plus tôt lors de
leur arrivée au cimetière des
palestiniens ont tiré sur le convoi
durant la cérémonie
nous entendrons plusieurs détonations
dans les montagnes voisines shlomo fait
le point avec ses hommes continuent à
tirer non ça fait que là on est toujours
là toujours sur le qui vive
malgré les tirs ont atteint les
funérailles continue sur tous les
visages
la même dignité la même douleur la même
colère
dès la fin de la cérémonie des
hélicoptères de combats interviennent
les échanges de tirs très violents ont
eu lieu à proximité
l'armée intervient lors avec des chars
tirant la mitrailleuse lourde
ici
de l'autre côté des palestiniens qui
apparemment avaient tiré les premiers
bilan provisoire de cet incident quatre
soldats israéliens touchés par des
pierres et quatre blessés par balles
côté palestinien à gaza les écoles
reprenait ce matin nos activités nous
étions avec karim chapron gilles jaquet
talal abou rahmeh dans le quartier
d'albert âge dans un établissement
scolaire pris en charge par l'onu comme
beaucoup d'autres à gaza mais s'était
collé particulière désormais c'était
celle que fréquentait moi mais de
l'enfant palestinien tué le 30 septembre
dernier ses camarades de classe doivent
maintenant apprendre à faire eux aussi
leur deuil
dans toutes les écoles palestiniennes la
journée commence à manca blement par
l'hymne national
mais cette école du camp d'al barrage à
gaza est un peu spécial
ces lacs étudier le petit mohamed dans
le 30 septembre
maintenant vous allez assister à la
scène de netzarim au cours de laquelle
votre camarade a été tué
l'exacte réplique de ce qui s'est passé
devant l'objectif du cameraman de france
talal abou rare mais nous faisons ceci
pour faire oublier aux élèves cette
situation c'est un principe sicot
logique plus on répète une situation est
plus facilement on peut l'évacuer il
était assis ici c'était sa place il
avait écrit son nom en arabe mohamed ali
je lui apprenez l'anglais
c'était un excellent élève la vie
continue les cours ont repris
aujourd'hui dans cette école mais les
élèves de la classe de mohamed sans pour
l'heure loin d'avoir oublié leur
camarade ahmed et c'est gentil il avait
joué il aimait ses amis quand j'ai vu ça
j'avais la gorge nouée
je voulais tuer les israéliens
quand je les ai vus à la télé j'étais
jeté des pierres je demande à tous les
arabes de cercles bleus restent bola
résultat quand on demande aujourd'hui à
ses enfants s'il croit à la paix avec
israël aucune main ne se lève le
diplomate de très nombreux pays dont les
américains les européens multiplient
coup de téléphone contacts directs et
propositions pour tenter de calmer le
jeu de mettre sur pied un sommet
israélo-palestinien
il serait elle exige comme préalable le
retour de trois de ses soldats détenus
par le hezbollah chiite libanais hier
secrétaire général de l'onu kofi annan
affirmé qu'ils étaient en bonne santé et
bien traités mais monsieur kofi annan a
remis son déplacement au liban dans ce
contexte on a noté le déplacement en
europe
d'abord en italie et hier puis à paris
aujourd'hui de l'ancien premier ministre
ennemi shimon peres
celui ci affirme qu'il n'y a plus de
difficultés entre les dirigeants
français dirigeants d'israël
interrogé par jean marc et 12 avec nom
et pierre cassignard l'ancien prix nobel
de la paix est devenu émissaire d'ehud
barak part de compromis toujours
possible on ne paie pas à tuer au sort
convainc pas tuer la vie la paix se
lever à mon avis malgré tous les soucis
et malgré tous les problèmes il faut on
peut rénover le processus d'oslo est
actuellement israéliens et palestiniens
sont disponibles pour cette terre d
israël
oui clairement les parisiens pensaient
peut être un mal âge entre le terrorisme
et les négociations impossibles à mon
avis pas possible il ya quelques
principes sur les négociations
d'abord nous ne pouvons pas imposer
notre avis sur les palestiniens
elle ne peut rester muet pas imposer
leur avis sur nous aussi c'est au tour
de joe hachem c'est la même chose il
faut chercher un compromis entre charles
enderlin ça négocie donc beaucoup et un
peu tous azimuts et pourtant ce que ça
avance bien écouter kofi annan espérait
conclure un accord cet après-midi ce
n'est pas le cas
il prolonge son séjour dans la région de
24 heures et poursuit ses navettes entre
ehud barak à jérusalem et il ya c'est
rare à pâte à gaza la pierre
d'achoppement vous l'avez dit c'est
toujours l'exigence de yasser arafat de
la formation d'une commission d' enquête
internationale que refuse monsieur barak
alors que donc les diplomates eux
proposent des formules de remplacement
une mission d'experts internationaux
parmi lesquels arafat lui exige nelson
mandela barak refuse
et ce n'est pas tout yasser arafat exige
l'application de tous les accords
intérimaires avant de reprendre le
chemin de la négociation d'une
négociation de paix même pas encore le
cessez-le-feu est là il exige l'arrêt de
la construction dans toutes les
implantations juives comme le stipulent
les accords d'oslo
j'évoquais il y un instant charles les
propos de monsieur shimon peres qui dit
que ça va mieux entre la france et
israël est ce que vous avez confirmation
tout à fait cela va mieux depuis hier
après midi le président français a pris
l'initiative d'une communication
téléphonique avec ehud barak
on m'a dit que la conversation n'était
pas franchement amical mais beaucoup
plus que correct n'a été question des
efforts pension en vue d'obtenir la
libération des trois soldats prisonniers
au liban l'ambassadeur de france à
beyrouth a même rencontré des dirigeants
du réseau là on n'en sait pas plus en
tout cas les relations franco israélien
aujourd'hui vont un peu mieux
merci chat la police de l'air et des
frontières de roissy a retenu pendant
quatre jours une enfant de 8 ans parlant
français d'origine comorienne sous le
prétexte de vérification d'identité une
rétention policière à laquelle une juge
des enfants a mis fin pour avoir
constaté l'état de choc de la fillette
cette histoire sur laquelle les
autorités policières ont bien du mal à
fournir toutes les explications illustre
de nouveau l'absence de réel contrôle de
ces zones d'accueil aux frontières
reportage stephen breitner et yannick
aroussi mais la famille de catherine
n'en revient toujours pas mardi dernier
son père l'attendait à la sortie de
l'avion en provenance des comores
mais une fois tous les passagers sortis
pas 2,4 y y
aux juristes et des eaux pour attendre
ma fille j'ai passé deux heures d or et
j ministre commet sa mine qui en fait
cette petite française de 8 ans est
entre les mains de la police de l'air et
des frontières motifs faux passeport
elle est donc placées en zones
d'attentes dans cet hôtel de roissy
accompagné d'une petite fille calme très
discrète qui ne parlait pas c'est vrai
qu'elle nous a demandé si on avait de
l'aspirine parce qu'elle avait mal de
tête mais nous sommes en très bonne
santé elle a mangé au restaurant
normalement trois jours plus tard la
cimade une association d'aidé aux
étrangers arrivent à joindre ses parts
non lorsque son père se présentent aux
policiers dialogue de sourds on a fait
tous les papiers frein si ramdane dit
enfin si la mienne et celle de mam un
livre de famille extrait de naissance
qu'on est elle est née à marseille mais
il ne dissipe pas votre fille samedi
matin catherine est présenté au juge
pour enfants de bobigny
la petite fille vient visiblement de
vivre un calvaire oui ça ne m'est jamais
arrivé qu'un enfant lorsque je la proche
on lui parle on comme je parle
normalement un enfant lève les bras
comme ça en se protégeant et en disant
je veux pas tu vois je veux pas te
parler tu es méchante je ne vois pas ce
qui a permis de dire que la photo sur le
passeport ne correspondait pas à
l'enfant j'avais devant moi
convaincu que le passeport de catherine
est un vrai la juge ordonne
immédiatement sa remise en liberté au
ministère de l'intérieur on répond par
un long communiqué et on explique que la
police ne pouvait laisser pénétrer cette
jeune mineur dont le passeport étaient
falsifiés sur le territoire national
pour un doute sur son identité
catherine a passé quatre jours en
isolement à 8 ans comme une clandestine
mais française devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris où l'on examine
depuis plus d'une semaine un dossier de
financement présumé occulte du parti
communiste par des entreprises
le secrétaire national du ps et robert
hue a nié tout financement de la sorte
ce même pour lui un principe politique
at-il dit monsieur a donc été
catégorique devant un tribunal
il est vrai que dans le dossier aucune
preuve matérielle rapporté n'atteste
d'apports financiers illicites compte
rendu de may verdeilhan et vincent
ferreira
une chemise à la main ce n'est pas un
discours mais sa défense sous forme de
petites fiches cartonnées robert hue ne
les utilisera pas un moment dit il où
l'on s'interroge si les plus hautes
autorités de l'état doivent s'expliquer
devant la justice
moi je suis là avec force le numéro 1 du
pc contre attaque le financement de
notre parti ce sont les cotisations les
subventions le reversement des salaires
des élus 140 millions de francs par an
et la vente du muguet 10 millions en une
seule journée
le trésor du parti ce sont nos militants
martèle robert hue une défense politique
contre la main basse des entreprises
privées sur les collectivités locales
dit il nous faisons de la résistance pas
seulement contre la compagnie générale
des eaux
aujourd'hui plus que jamais je suis pour
la nationalisation de l'eau en dix ans
poursuit-il
il n'y a jamais eu d'accord entre la cge
et des municipalités communistes
on n'achète ni les votes ni les âmes des
élus communistes conclut énergiquement
robert e convaincre c'est le souci
premier d'un homme politique mais pour
robert hue aujourd'hui il ne s'agissait
pas de convaincre des électeurs mais des
magistrats et c'est peut-être son combat
le plus dur de sa carrière face à un
procureur muet à l'audience mais restant
dans sa logique d'accusation face à un
tribunal qui semble peu sensible aux
arguments développés par le prévenu
robert hue
dure journée judiciaire pour le
secrétaire national du parti communiste
français qui annonce au tribunal que la
loi qui porte son nom sur le contrôle
des fonds publics a été voté aujourd'hui
par l'assemblée nationale
pour robert hue c'est un argument mais
c'est aussi une mince consolation dans
la sphère des hlm de la ville de paris
les magistrats de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel ont
validé la mise en examen de jean tiberi
celui ci veut maintenant se pourvoir en
cassation en revanche l'annulation des
mises en examen de messieurs roussin et
pendre aux deux anciens ministres rpr et
puis l'un des proches très proches de
jean tiberi le directeur du crédit
municipal de paris gi de gris vient
d'être démis
fonctions par la commission bancaire
pour je cite manque d'expérience
controverse entre les juges
d'instruction chargés de l'affairé elf
et le ministère d'économie il avait
demandé la levée du secret défense sur
les documents relatifs aux commissions
versées à l'étranger par le groupe elf
il estime n'avoir pas reçu tous les
documents en question
ils ont donc renouvelé leur demande ce
soir laurent fabius a fait savoir qu'il
avait suivi lui intégralement l'avis de
la commission secret défense
commentaire audio caroff avec are seen
leibovitch laurent fabius
at-il vraiment lever le secret défense
sur la paix règne il n'a pas envie de
répondre
elisabeth guigou non plus depuis 24
heures les deux ministres le savent
le scandale politico financier risque de
déboucher sur un bras de fer entre le
gouvernement et un juge d'instruction
renaud van ruymbeke chargé d'une partie
du dossier demandent depuis deux mois
des documents importants pour son
enquête la liste des commissions
occultes versées par elf de 89 à 93 ces
commissions figurent noir sur blanc dans
un document tout à fait officielle
chaque année le groupe pétrolier en
remettait un exemplaire à l'elysée un
proche de françois mitterrand
le second aller au ministère du budget
alors dirigé par michèle charras ces
documents stockés ici à la direction
nationale des douanes été classé secret
défense
une commission consultative les a
épluché aujourd'hui l'un de ses membres
l'admet le secret n'a été levée que pour
une petite partie des listes l'essentiel
reste inaccessible le secret défense est
évidemment le secret militaire mais
c'est aussi tout ce qui touche les
intérêts stratégiques de la france
chacun comprendra que les
approvisionnements pétroliers font
partie intérêts centraux de la nation ça
touche aussi les accords internationaux
et là nous sommes en plein dans les
accords internationaux juste mot lors du
rachat de cette raffinerie à l'ena en
allemagne 300 millions de francs se sont
évaporés il aurait pu servir à financer
le parti d'helmut kohl en maintenant le
secret défense on freine peut-être
l'enquète mais on a créé toute une idée
l'affairé elf est bien une affaire
d'état les mouvements de protestation
des syndicats des gardiens de prison
n'ont pas cessé aujourd'hui la rencontre
entre les représentants syndicaux de
nice
10 à bien eu lieu mais sans effet
immédiat sur la graphie continuent de
bloquer de très nombreux centres de
détention il y a dix jours le chalutier
and oriente de lorient faisait naufrage
au large de l'irlande sur les onze
membres de l'équipage seuls trois marins
un français deux portugais ont survécu
cet après midi à sainte anne d'auray
dans le morbihan 3000 personnes
assistaient à une cérémonie religieuse
en hommage aux disparus
mais aujourd'hui le syndicat des
personnes de l'administration de la mer
affirme que le chalutier n'avez pas le
droit de naviguer accusation contestée
par le propriétaire armateur du navire
en cas de patrick fandio et christophe
medard
huiles vierges pour huit disparus huit
morts dont six français perdus en mer il
y a dix jours l'hommage sobre des
familles des proches des amis
il ya là le capitaine de la nourrir seul
rescapé français de la tragique campagne
de pêche
le capitaine savait que son chalutier
n'étaient pas en règle l'âne orient
qu'on voit ici dans ce film tourné en
1987 n'avait pas de permis de navigation
en quittant le port de lorient
ce qui n'a pas empêché l'armateur pétrel
de le faire appareiller
c'est cet homme qui a révélé
l'information ce matin pour lui c'est
clair
le chalutier breton était hors la loi le
principe est que ce chat lui tienne
n'avez pas le droit de prendre la mer
sans titre de navigation
eh bien il a pris la mer parce qu'il
avait sans doute un certificat d'un
organisme privé qui attestaient que les
vérifications avaient été faites les
vérifications il y en a effectivement tu
sur le chalutier quelques minutes avant
qu'il ne prenne la mer
l'armateur pétrels api renvoi fait
toutes les réparations notamment la
corrosion sur l'appareil à gouverner
pour lui le permis de navigation n'était
qu'une formalité
si le navire n'avait pas pu naviguer
il est évident que les affaires
maritimes qui ont su que le navire sans
nallet aurait réagi pas moins de trois
enquêtes sont en cours pour expliquer le
naufrage
l'armateur est sur la sellette selon des
juristes les familles pourraient se
retourner contre lui pour exiger des
dédommagements sans permis de naviguer
les hommes n'avaient rien à faire en mer
sur recommandation de l'agencé française
de sécurité sanitaire des aliments le
minisère gré culture jean glavany a
décidé de prendre toutes les précautions
et d'interdire l'utilisation d'intestin
bovins des précautions seront également
prises à venir des sharks crise importée
l'explication jean bernard schmidt
il en est fier de ses saucisses tout
comme de ces boudins ou de ces
andouilles est géré araujo les faits lui
même à la main et satisfaction
supplémentaire lui les fabriques sans
utiliser de boyaux de boeuf comme
enveloppe il a pris les devants on a
déjà anticipé le problème on savait très
bien qu'il ya trois quatre ans le centre
technique vous avez juste venu que le
boyau étaient contaminés et qui pouvait
y avoir des conséquences et aujourd'hui
on fabrique tous à base de cochon mais
tous les producteurs n'ont pas pris les
mêmes précautions
bon nombre utilisent encore les boyaux
de boeuf le problème c'est que les
intestins de bovins sont suspectés de
transmettre la maladie de la vache folle
le gouvernement a donc décidé ce matin
de les interdits en effet selon les
études le raclage utilisé comme ici pour
traiter les intestins n'est pas
considéré comme une technique assez sur
coup dur pour les fabricants de boyaux
il leur faut réagir
nous avions pris nous une option de nous
approvisionner en boyaux de boeuf est
quasi exclusivement en provenance de
pays où a priori cette maladie n'était
pas susceptible de se développer
c'est à dire principalement l'amérique
du sud en prenant cette mesure
d'interdiction
le gouvernement français appuie
pleinement le principe de précaution et
il entend être suivi il est clair que
tout ce que nous décidons en france ça
serait bien ça soit harmonisée au plan
européen d'ailleurs nous le demandons et
nous le demanderons à chaque fois que
nous prenons une mesure supplémentaire
nous disons voilà ce que nous disent nos
scientifiques nous souhaitons que cette
interdiction soit prise au niveau
européen
en france en tout cas les intestins de
boeuf sont désormais considérés à risque
tout comme la cervelle la rate ou la
moelle épinière
un peu plus d'un mois après la rentrée
scolaire dans l'enseignement
professionnel on sent comme un vide les
lycées pro perdent des élèves 26000 deux
mois en deux ans et le paradoxe est
inquiétant puisque dans de très
nombreuses spécialités techniques les
entreprises recherchent de la main
d'oeuvre
c'est vrai dans le bâtiment les métiers
du bâtiment sont délaissés trop dur peu
valorisants quelquefois mal payés au
lycée professionnel michelet de nantes
les pénuries d'élèves la pénurie
d'élèves équivaut à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans les entreprises reportage
et la nuque et maryse richard plâtrier
une spécialité qui devient rare le lycée
professionnel michelet pourrait
accueillir deux fois plus d'élèves dans
cet atelier
mais les candidats ne se bousculent pas
à tort les offres d'emploi se ramassent
à la pelle
c'est un métier qui salle qui était dur
donc maintenant faut trouver du monde
donc vous faites pas de souci pour votre
emploi là au nom en peinture aussi les
débouchés sont nombreux
même les filles se sont convertis
certaine que leur réussite est à portée
de pinceaux sont beaucoup de patience et
pierre s'appliquer va prendre fin je
pense ici plus facile personne
maçonnerie plomberie serrurerie presque
toutes les disciplines sont en
sous-effectif c'est peut-être lié aussi
à l'image de marque de certains métiers
du bâtiment mais nous avons
effectivement des places vacantes et
nous avons perdu
disons depuis quatre ans 150 élèves au
moins et pourtant les offres d'emploi
foisonnent jusqu'à 10 par jour à la
belle saison quand les chantiers
reprennent
les entreprises n'hésitent pas à
solliciter les élèves avant même qu'ils
aient obtenu leur diplôme
un patron qui a plu chez moi et chercher
des personnes pour former mal à
travailler donc
le gie refusé ne se sont tenus aux
études car partout où on construit on
rénove depuis deux ans l'activité a
augmenté de plus de 5% dans le bâtiment
pendant les années de crise on a opéré
225000 licenciement alors aujourd'hui on
manque de bras on peut par former
plusieurs milliers d'emplois en quelques
semaines c'est pas possible
donc c'est vrai qu'on s'est laissé les
entreprises sur laisser surprendre
et aujourd'hui les entreprises
s'arrachent la main d'oeuvre ou
d'augmentation de salaire quatre-vingt
mille emplois sont nécessaires en france
les chantiers prennent du retard
ah ben c'est simple nous sommes passés
de délai de quinze jours trois semaines
à six semaines en délais actuellement
nous prenons du travail
nous prenons le travail ne pouvons pas
nous engager avant minimum 3 mois et
vous refusez des chantiers et nous
refusons les chantiers
quand le bâtiment va on connaît l'adage
encore faut-il ne pas manquer de
l'essentiel la main d'or
les cotations boursières à la baisse la
bourse électronique nasdaq à new york a
effacé un an de hausse et à paris la
bourse a perdu plus de 3% en cause les
valeurs technologiques et les
télécommunications paris désormais sous
les 6000 points ou cac 40 comme en des
199 le site des changes de musique sur
internet napster est menacé de fermeture
par la justice américaine
on l'accuse ni plus ni moins de piratage
la technologie de napster permet aux
particuliers d'échanger gratuitement de
la musique sur internet les fichiers
musiques sont mis à disposition le site
aurait ainsi conquis plus de 25 millions
d'utilisateurs dans le monde en quelques
mois les éditeurs musicaux sont très
inquiets ils évoquent la violation des
droits d'auteur mais comment l'empêcher
les habitués du site napster ont montré
à daniel wolfromm et claude bernier
comment ils opéraient ils ne tiennent
pas à être connu leur visage restera
donc dissimuler leur passion la musique
qu'ils copient allègrement sur internet
grâce à un site gratuit
nap's times du son le son est très bon
c'est son studio comment vous allez
voter sur la chaîne si tu veux te graver
et la pochette c'est beau c'est d'abord
le récupère la pochette gens arrêtent
aussi il ya des citoyens mais toutes les
pochettes même si c'est pas très légal
mais on peut la récupérer sans trembler
si tu veux en ce soir tu rentres chez
toi de la motion le goût phare de la
musique rock britannique
leur dernier album vient à peine de
sortir mais déjà depuis plus d'un mois
il est disponible offert à tous sur
napster
napster est un gigantesque jukebox
planétaire mais à la différence du
vénérable appareils des années 50
napster ne coûte pas un sou au 25
millions d'utilisateurs et il s'échange
chaque mois près d'un milliard et demi
le titre réaction brutale des maisons de
disques procès contre napster des
artistes montent en ligne pour défendre
leurs droits d'auteur leur chef de file
en amérique le groupe metallica
pour nous c'est la même chose que de
rentrer dans un magasin de disques de
ramasser un cd de metallica et de partir
en courant l'europe est aussi brutal que
celui de metallica
comme eux ils vendent des millions de
disques pourtant les smashing pumpkins
ont diffusé gratuitement leur dernier
album sur internet
je crois que la liberté beaucoup plus
importante que le commerce quand il
s'agit d'heures on a voulu cet album
gratuit justement ce pour sortir des
contraintes imposées par les maisons de
disques mais comment les artistes
pourront type gagner leur vie ces jeunes
gens eux sont nés avec internet
difficile de les convaincre que tout
service doit pas être rémunéré est-ce
que tu serais d'accord pour payer à a
pris un abonnement comme tu accèdes
d'aller payer le 34 40 franche et patron
de safran pour aller au cinéma
je paye mon abonnement et en plus les
communications téléphoniques ça mais un
bon service et un bon service
moi tu peux te dire je paye un
abonnement moi je suis convaincu d'une
chose et j'espère que les maisons disent
qu'on s'y mette leur aplomb possible
c'est de développer une offre les sites
est légal et je crois que ça c'est le
plus important
faire payer napster est peut-être une
solution mais il se crée sans cesse
d'autres sites des changes de musique et
sur internet
les pirates sont légion sport cyclisme
au championnat du monde de plouay tout
le public breton à supporter jeannie
longo cet après midi lors du
contre-la-montre féminin la multiple
championne française n'a été devancé que
de un peu plus de trois secondes par
l'américaine mary holden c'est donc une
très belle deuxième place pour jeannie
longo
nous allons retrouver dans un instant
après ce reportage natale de axa et
alain poirier ces championnats du monde
jeannie longo les a préparés chez
l'habitante une bretonne n'a pas hésité
à ouvrir les portes de sa maison à la
française juste avant sa course
il faut dire que dans la région longo et
populaire
elle a pratiquement mon âge
j'admire les sportives et du caractère
elle a du caractère et c'est ça qui lui
après remise certainement d'arriver à
ceux de la voilà tout au long des 25 km
du parcours
ils étaient des milliers à pousser la
française vers son 12e titre mondial
jeannie longo s'est dépensé sans compter
pour finalement échouer quatre secondes
derrière l'américaine holden
disons que
ça fait quand même trois ans que j'ai
pas de titre mondial ou voilà sur le
podium des championnats du monde de
plouay malgré son bouquet de fleurs et
sa médaille d'argent
jeannie longo semblait inconsolable non
c'est pas vrai jeannie longo vous êtes
intérêts de plouay bonsoir vous n'êtes
pas inconsolable c'est formidable
aujourd'hui non oui oui je suis quand
même contente c'est sûrement parce qu'on
peut toujours faire un petit peu mieux
et je sais où j'ai perdu ses quatre
secondes mais dis donc un championnat du
monde en octobre n'est pas là pour
favoriser parce que le temps
malheureusement est un temps automnal et
donc avec la froidure
ouais alors médaille de bronze ciney
médaille d'argent ici à plouay vous avez
un palmarès incomparable vous avez
toujours encore envie de gagner quelque
chose
ni à l'avancé quand même en france je
vous avoue l'avait signalé le public
était vraiment très très chaleureux
m'encourager beaucoup bon c'est toujours
bien d'avoir d'avoir un titre en france
mais une deuxième place au site est beau
c'est surtout le je pense que le match
que nous avons eu entre mary mary holden
et moi même
bon c'était c'était assez prenant je
pense qu'on a fait un beau spectacle
alors on va parler d'âge on va vous
souhaitez par avance un bon anniversaire
quarante deux ans court la fin à la fin
du mois qu'est ce qui vous fait encore
qu'est ce qui vous donne encore envie de
monter sur un vélo de me mettre un
casque et d'y aller avec des jeunes
filles qui sont quand même un petit peu
plus jeune que vous oui des fois je
regardais les les jeunes qui sont tous
deux moins bons qu'ils n'ont peut-être
pas te plaît le même visage mais je
pense que je suis toujours compétitive
et je crois que c'est la passion qui
m'anime comme comme tous ceux qui font
leur métier avec passion et qui
poursuivent tant qu'il sent que ils ont
encore justement cette motivation et
qu'ils ont encore des des choses qui les
anime chaque jour qui ne sont pas à
l'ouvragé qui vont en traînant les pieds
quand ils vont faire quelque chose vous
avez déjà une idée du moment où vous
allez raccroché le vélo vous allez
commencer à regarder les autres non
disons que j'ai j'oriente ma carrière de
toute façon tout à fait différente j'ai
fait des choix
ces dernières années bon c'est vrai que
les grandes courses par étapes
je n'en fais j'en fais de moins en moins
parce que c'est de plus en plus dur pour
moi de justement de m'aligner au départ
tous les jours avec un dossard et
d'avoir cet esprit justement de
compétitions tous les jours donc je fais
des choix et c'est comme ça aussi que
j'arrive à me faire plaisir encore alors
jeannie longo rhône c'est que vous avez
souvent des difficultés avec les
dirigeants du g tissu français vous avez
l'impression que maintenant on vous aime
mieux et bien du fait que je sois devenu
plus sereine et plus maître de ce que je
fais j'ai pu en fait j'ai quand même une
j'ai une certaine ouverture de dialogue
de discussions avec le président et le
directeur technique national et donc je
peux dire que ça se passe bien ces
dernières années bien merci beaucoup et
puis donc bon anniversaire à voir mr
freeze tag aux grandes journées de
versailles c'est l'intégrale du
compositeur couperin qui sera joué dix
concerts au château de versailles 17
autres dans plusieurs institutions
parisiennes permettront d'apprécier la
musique de celui qui fut organiste et
claveciniste de la chambre de louis xiv
ces grandes journées vont ainsi faire
planer l'ombre de couperin dans
l'illustrent déco royal de versailles
que nous raconte michel pontet philippe
usi avec pour le début de cette
intégrale couperin les leçons de
ténèbres au beau milieu de la nuit
il arrivait par là invariablement de ses
appartements vers cette chapelle royale
sa chapelle royale
et au coeur de la nuit dans son
versailles encore assoupie et plein de
l'ombre le roi soleil venait à la
rencontre du seul interlocuteur digne de
son rang
dieu lui même
mais alors que les courtisans sont
encore endormis les artistes et les rois
se réveille réveil des visages des corps
des voix pour honorer la musique divine
d'un certain couperin compositeur d'un
roi très mélomane le moindre chanteur de
cette chapelle été recruté après avoir
été auditionné trois fois par le roi en
personne à chaque psaume achevé une
bougie devaient être éteints une lumière
s'évanouissent et pour en laisser naître
une autre d'arrivée de l'homme
c'est leçon des ténèbres c'est une
offrande une offrande dans les voûtes
pour louis xiv silencieux qui est contée
dans la nuit ce cadeau royal
au 20e siècle
les horaires sont désormais plus sage
l'intégrale couperin c'est comme un
voyage obtenu dans un univers où les
couleurs ne compte plus seule restait
les nuances infinies du noir au moins
l'intégrale de couperin à versailles
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition
je vous rappelle deux informations nous
avons développé les violences qui
continuent toujours entre israéliens et
palestiniens de jeunes palestiniens ont
été tués aujourd'hui les efforts
internationaux qui se multiplient pour
un éventuel sommet entre ehud barak il
essaiera fap
mais les effets des crises au
proche-orient- eu de graves conséquences
en france une synagogue à trappes dans
les yvelines a été détruite
et puis la décision du gouvernement
d'interdire l'utilisation dans
l'alimentation de la totalité des
intestins de bovins le doyen considéré
comme à risques après la météo qui vous
sera présenté par isabelle martinez sur
france 2 vers et madame le proviseur
avec charlotte de turckheim puis ça se
discute avec jean luc delarue le journal
de la nuit avec laurence piquet à zéro
heure 40 et des mots de minuit avec
philippe lefait juste après à une heure
du matin demain dans les 4 vérités à
7h53 me rends à recevra aimé jacquet
pour l'opération donnons des couleurs à
l'hôpital à 13h votre vrai donc gérard
holtz à demain 20h bonsoir merci
non